all right let's get to it then fill in
the blank and caroline is the first
topic their two and two start is what
utterly surprising
from the standpoint of
personnel
and everything they lose quickly they
you know they lose cam they lose
mccaffrey now in it you know with an
injury and they're 2-0 cents so i'd say
utterly surprising
and i agree with you i never would have
expected this i i
you know when they when they came close
to beating the raiders it's like maybe
the raiders just aren't very good right
but but when they when they uh rattle
off back-to-back wins uh games they
should have lost without christian
mccaffrey it just makes me wonder
where this thing's going and how much
better they'll be when mccaffrey comes
back unlike a lot of those week two
injuries that were season ending
mccaffrey's isn't he'll be back and
they'll be far better off for it all
right ron rivera's decision to bench
washington quarterback dwayne haskins
for kyle allen is what
unconventional yet
in my opinion inspiring
and the reason is
that everybody would say hey listen
you've got to be able to give dwayne
haskins a fair shot you've got to see
what he can do this year so you know
whether you have your quarterback in
2021 and you know what if the dallas
cowboys were 4-0 right now i bet that's
what he would do i bet he would not have
made that change this week but in going
to kyle allen he's going to a guy
and hey matt do we have the schedule of
the washington football team i mean i
hate using that do we have washington's
schedule that we can put on the screen
because if we do i want you to look at
the next six games for washington
because all of those games
with the possible exception of this week
hosting the rams now that is a really
really tough game but maybe you have to
count on the rams
coming to the east coast three separate
occasions in the first five weeks but
then i want you to look at the next five
games
at the giants cowboys at home
at you know giants at home then at the
lions and then the bengals so
if you're ron rivera and you look at
this schedule you have to say why not us
and what quarterback are they most
comfortable that gives them the best
chance to win
this week
it's not dwayne haskins it's kyle allen
who knows this offense better and who is
more at one
uh with uh offensive coordinator scott
turner
and i'm gonna say it's temporary because
i think this is just a stepping stone
to alex smith being back on the field
and that would be the final scene of the
disney movie that is destined to be made
about everything alex smith has been
through over the past couple of years to
come back from that badly broken leg
with the infection that nearly resulted
in amputation and death
for for alex smith to fight back to come
back and and i think one of the reasons
he's not
already the starter they they just want
to they just want to be sure they want
to be 100 sure that he can protect
himself
when they put him out there on the field
and just give it a little more time and
a little more time but you know kyle
allen got benched late last year because
he wasn't getting it done for carolina
this is a band-aid until alex smith is
ready but they didn't want to give
dwayne haskins any more reps because
they just weren't comfortable with his
performance in the system that will be
the system for as long as ron rivera is
there all right peter what do you got
mike
the one thing that i think is really
interesting about what you just said i
agree with you i do think at some point
alex smith is going to take the field
for washington this year and when he
does the first snap that he takes
alex smith will win my vote for comeback
player of the year i ca if he plays one
snap
he will get my vote for comeback player
of the year because nobody in my opinion
i've covered the nfl for 36 years
never in my life have i seen a player
come back from an injury as devastating
as alex smith has
and
in my opinion we can't applaud the guy
enough
yeah i agree with you i agree with you
no matter what he does just the mere
fact of being in uniform crossing the
thick white stripe and entering the
field again
when the last time you were there look
at what happened to you why do you even
want to do it to muster the will and the
desire it shows his passion for the
sport his determination it's inspiring
and you're right
i could say you could make the argument
you should get the vote now but if he
gets on the field i agree with you he
definitely should get every vote for
comeback player of the year all right if
the cowboys can't beat the giants
what
um
i think they might have to fire mike
nolan
and i don't say that lightly
but
you know and obviously mike neither of
us
are pff tape gurus
okay
but this past week
you're starting to see the tape gurus
saying man dallas not giving a full
effort on on defense
you know some of those guys
look like they're either in a fog
confused not giving full effort and you
know to me it's time for mike mccarthy
this week to walk down the uh the
hallway stick his head into mike nolan's
office
and say hey mike
you got to simplify things
you got to get our players to just
simply be out there playing football
reacting we're too good
uh to not uh you know to be playing this
way but i will say one other thing
when everybody on the cowboys was
talking about hey let's go get earl
thomas i kept saying
you know in my little apartment in
brooklyn well wait a second you don't
need earl thomas go talk snax harrison
into coming to play for you pay him
whatever it takes even though you're
snug up against the cap anyway and you
know what
john schneider the general manager of
the seattle seahawks recognized that he
needed snacks harrison and i don't know
whether the cowboys went far down the
road with him or not but they absolutely
should have because this is a team
that i mean just look at that
172 rushing yards a game that's
disgraceful
and the cowboys have to turn it around
and look it's a great week to play the
giants the new york giants have played
four games this year they haven't scored
17 points yet
so you would think you watch this game
if daniel jones riddles these guys if
devante freeman or wayne gallman you
know rushes for 80 or 100.
there has got to be a day of reckoning
on monday morning
in frisco texas at the start
especially since it's jason garrett
running that offense that makes it even
worse that raises the stakes and i agree
with you i think mike nolan's going to
be out if they lose this game i think
jerry jones will have read the riot act
to everyone and it doesn't take a tape
guru to watch the odell beckham jr
touchdown run that iced the game and
pick out the loafs of bread on the
dallas side of the equation the guys not
giving effort to try to go
tackle odell beckham jr or at least
knock him out of bounds
there's five or six guys that aren't
going all out i don't know if they just
thought alton smith's gonna tackle him
in the backfield and we shut down oh no
he got away and then they never kick in
the go tackle the guy gene
but uh that's not acceptable and you're
right and and you know the separate
question is why do you even hire mike
nolan to run the defense when he's gonna
use a system that doesn't fit the guys
you have that's the head scratcher and
that falls on mike mccarthy's lap so
problems in dallas again
they have the talent every year but
there's always an issue when it comes to
getting the most out of it and winning
football games all right last one real
quickly lamar jackson's knee injury
which has kept him from practicing both
wednesday and thursday of this week is
what peter
i would call it
troublesome
for the quarter pole your favorite term
the for the quarter pole of the season
and it's because
look every week the baltimore ravens
play with fire they don't like to talk
about it but they do lamar jackson runs
a lot
and last year hey happy days are here
again he set the all-time record for
rushing yards by a quarterback in one
season
and hey he was terrific totally deserved
to be unanimous mvp
everything is great
but that doesn't mean that every year
that lamar jackson plays
that he's going to have no physical
problems with exposing himself to a lot
of hard hits beyond the line of
scrimmage
i'm not even suggesting right now mike
that he change
i'm simply suggesting
this is
simply a cost of doing business
for uh john harbaugh greg roman and
lamar jackson if this is the way you
want to play on offense then lamar
jackson having a bum knee on october 9th
is going to be what's going to happen it
might not happen every year but it's
going to happen some years
yeah i call it alarming because it isn't
all that hard to scrape together enough
activity at practice to justify putting
him down as a limited participant which
sends
far less dramatic
red flags up than not practicing at all
it again you don't have to do much to be
limited and for him to not be practicing
at all tells me they're doing everything
they can to work on that knee to treat
that knee to get the knee ready to go on
sunday when they host the cincinnati
bengals and joe burrow which
could become one hell of a rivalry if
the bengals can put some players around
their first oral pick in the draft all
right we have time for our last one your
expectations for joe flacco's first
start as a member of the new york jets
or what peter
exceedingly low
i mean
i think the players around joe flacco
make the expectations what they are that
plus the fact that you watch him play
quarterback in denver last year
and you know he looks slow
um you know he's not necessarily a
problem solver
uh in in in a football game right now
and especially when he doesn't have
great weapons
and to say the jets don't have great
weapons is like saying i'm 20 pounds
overweight no duh
and so i kind of look at this right now
and say
it's nice that they have an experienced
guy to be a backup instead of a practice
squad player that's great good for the
jets but i don't think it means that
they're going to come close to winning
this game
yeah i i agree with you there's just too
many problems too many issues and
they've got six more games until they're
by and uh
i can't find the win between now and the
point where it seems inevitable that
they're going to pull the plug on what's
happening in new york
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports